presence means being sensible thinking
carefully through what will this mean
for the community what will it mean for
the next generation see what the West is
really done is robbed its children and
his grandchildren are the things that
we've taken for granted I'm Dave Rubin
and this is the Rubin report as long as
you're here don't forget to click that
little subscribe button and tap that
Bell over there so that you actually see
our videos crazy I know all right
joining me today is the former Deputy
Prime Minister of Australia a relentless
fighter for freedom and the host of
conversations with John John Anderson
welcome to the Rubin report glad to be
with you too really I am very happy to
have you here because I'll start by
saying that something that I'd never
have told you in person even though
we've met a couple times you reached out
to me about three years ago right when
we built this studio and the show was
taken off there was a nice little bump
in what we were doing and you reached
out to me or your people reached out to
me and said John Anderson former Deputy
Prime Minister of Australia would like
to chat with you he's coming to LA and
it was really the first time that I
thought whoa this thing is seriously
international that the conversations
that I'm having are seriously important
then we had a great breakfast where we
talked about freedom and yeah we do
conversation and all of those things and
since we've done a couple events
together so I guess my first question is
you've been in this fight for a long
time when did you start becoming aware
that there was something worldwide
around having decent conversations that
was sort of becoming the new way of
going about discourse well in my my
initial sort of concerns around freedom
were largely economic so I was part of
the coalition government in Australia
from 1996 to 2007 and we were a
reforming government our emphasis on
freedom was economic freedom so that we
would not pass on debt burdens and lack
of opportunities to young people and
that was my focus I think for me it was
after the great financial crisis and you
saw the blame game started to really
play out and I started to see that we
needed to make major adjustments to the
way we ran our
he's in the West they're all hopelessly
indebted with the exception of a few
places like Australia but we wouldn't do
it we wouldn't own what we're done and
he started to see the shouting become
very shrill now it hadn't started then
but you asked when I started to realize
this is a real problem it was about that
point because I started to see that that
actually understood properly in
democracies governments downstream of
culture mm-hmm and so's economics and
the whole Lehman Brothers collapse was
about a collapsing standards but again
you didn't have a grappling with what
had gone on in terms of the ethics of it
bankers instead of saying what should I
do
how should I behave rather what can I
get away with how can I build a bigger
bundle for me and for those around me
and hang you know the people who bank
with us and who trust in us and rely on
us I thought and I started to think this
is getting really serious but then it
was the nature of the debate because it
wasn't a debate anymore yeah now you
can't get good public policy without a
good debate and you can't have a good
debate without a reasonable degree of
respect for the other person whose
dignity in standing so it's interesting
because I was a struggling stand-up when
Lehman Brothers crash and I used to work
in a comedy club handing out tickets in
Times Square right on the corner I think
it was it was either 50th or 51st and
Broadway that's where the Lehman
Brothers Building was and yes this huge
lit up you know massive digital display
building and I remember when it when it
went down it seems like another lifetime
ago but what's it like to be one of the
guys going hey everybody we're about to
go off a cliff here I mean that's that's
not what politicians want to do they
want to always give everybody all the
things that they want part of the
problem yeah yeah there is no doubt we
need to understand that a lot of this
rots started in the 1960s we gave up
talking about you know the big sort of
meta narratives Who am I what am I where
do I fit how does the world work it's
all too hard and you can understand that
in a way we've seen horrific wars would
say in the Great Depression let's live
for us now mm-hmm
and in an age of cheap credit we started
a rack up debt right across the Western
world you know it's not as if I'm
singling out one country your country
country we're all in we've all done it
hold on yeah and here's the rub in a
democracy so you consider mr.
congressman now listen I'll give you my
vote if you promise me XY or Z and mr.
congressman might know instinctively he
knows his stuff you wonder how many of
them well I shouldn't single out
American come right a lot of politicians
walk out they know as much as they
should
yeah they might rift over on us say look
that it's not a good way to do it we
can't afford it it'll come against your
children and your grandchildren unfunded
liabilities if it turned out to be a
nightmare but we said no no you don't
get over alright I'll give it to you
because it's on the never never and
Kings from of old of known that until
the credit runs out you could live
pretty well but when the credit does run
out it's a very different story so it
really I think it has its genesis in the
60s and this idea that it's all about me
I will do what I like with my life etc
cetera cetera we abandoned the golden
rule do unto others as you'd have them
do unto you
it's all about me now cuz most people
don't live like that but that became a
sort of prevailing ethos right we would
never live like that in our own lives
right I mean sometimes you do what most
of us have been in debt at some point I
racked up too much credit card stuff or
whatever it is but you would never just
well you can't I mean that's the thing
as an individual you can keep just
getting more credit as you keep not
paying things but somehow in
government's we seem to be able to do
that well I think that you know it takes
two to tango
I think the electorate the voters if you
like if demanded too much mm-hmm but
politicians who should have known better
right across the west have not been
prudent enough either and there's an
old-fashioned word called prudence it
was a classic virtue it went along with
integrity and courage and all of those
other ones
and prudence disappeared and the story
of Lehman Brothers in many ways the
disappearance of prudence presence means
being sensible thinking carefully
through what will this mean for the
community what will it mean for the next
generation see what the West has really
done is robbed its children and it's
grandchildren are the things that we've
taken for granted and and and look I
don't know what privileges because you
can adjust it a thousand ways but as I
understand it I think you and I would by
say we're very very fortunate people
when we've grown up in free society
we've
really wanted and and so forth but
though she should never be taken for
granted do you see a direct connection
then between us stop no longer asking
the big questions in the 60s to then
directly to well politicians then just
say here's more here's more here's more
more because because the people no
longer have the tools to understand why
that's actually not good that actually
really explains what's happening here in
America yeah well I do think that I
really do think that I think we are
paying a terrible price as my personal
view for washing out
you see I think for a long time I don't
think in particularly in my country was
ever particularly religious but there
was an idea that broadly speaking the
Christian view of the world
love your neighbor Europe accountable to
a higher authority you may dislike your
neighbor but they still have value and
Worth and dignity and I have to respect
that broadly same is true then it just
became seen as one of main truths now of
course we know there's open hostility to
traditional underlying beliefs in the
West on the part of I don't know what
you call them do you call them a lot of
the intelligentsia or the politically
correct or the people who ever
microphones or the elites whatever word
you want to use is enormous hostility
there says the stuffs dangerous and you
shouldn't expose your children to it but
what's the substitute what are we
putting up instead the idea of radical
autonomy oh my I will tase it a guess
that you would understand exactly what I
mean if I said to you I don't think you
ever find yourself in yourself you
actually find yourself by relating to
and serving others and being considerate
and in looking to see where you can make
a difference not just for yourself all
the time self-centeredness just destroys
well that's the I guess real irony of
the situation as we've removed some of
these traditional beliefs we've replaced
them with authoritarian movements they
don't seem to be replaced by freer
movements if there was something so
wrong with them you would think all
right well then freedom will replace
them but no it seems to always go the
other way
well very much so I'm a great believer
in the in the freedoms I don't think
you've never run an unbundling we've had
a debate in Australia what's the first
freedom and people say what's obviously
it's freedom of speech they say because
that's the one by which you defend all
the other freedoms but I think I want to
and join with Frank for roadie now and
that's an interesting story to herself I
would be seen as broadly speaking
classic liberals stroke conservative he
would not you know he was a student
radical in the 60s wonderful and
delightful man if you've not had him on
no I haven't forget him frank ferrer
Kent University but he would say if I
said to him I did I said to him do you
think freedom of speech it's the first
freedom he said no no no no he said you
should understand with your Christian
convictions that actually it was freedom
of conscience mm-hmm our forebears were
burning one another at the stake
and my grateful cruel appalling thing to
do to another human being because they
had a minority view and after a while
people sort of said well this isn't very
consistent with Christian charity and is
pretty barbaric and a stupid because a
person with a minority view today that
we burn at the stake may in fact be part
of a movement that tomorrow do you the
majority do you sense that sort of where
we're heading right now I'm going yeah
it really worries me there's a there's
an oar of triumphalism if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell